you know what I loved Miniatures did you
know that there's a scene with a
miniature flash flood and Dante's Peak
that we totally missed
hold up also there's crazy Miniatures
this week called League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen and an incredible character
that these days would be 100 CG the back
of the paint that is not an effect you
can get doing practically also we're
going to touch on why the Watchman movie
did something technologically that the
new Obi-Wan show could not whoa that's
rough it like gets darker yeah plus Sam
gets food poisoning in the middle of
this episode if you don't believe me
just watch that's why Sam's actually
going to be on the couch the moment the
central zone
so what's going on in the Cascades Camp
some activity around Dante's Peak
Dante's Peak we already looked at
Dante's Peaks yeah you already did
didn't you that was years ago also you
kind of missed I think one of the
coolest shots or sequences in the actual
film what do you mean you I guess wait
you weren't on the couch wait I wasn't
it was you guys in Freddy and you were
like oh cool volcanoes lava and right
beneath you unbeknownst to you was
actually something far more incredible
than any of that
oh look at this one
are those sticks that's gotta be a
miniature dicks it's not a real
waterfall that's not a real flash flood
whoa nice well that was pretty cool man
this is sick actually yeah this stuff
looks really nice damn look at that and
Miniatures are so pretty now watch this
shot
oh no wait wait hold up that's awesome I
love it
I'm gonna date on set that would be no
no what wait wait
all right it appears you guys just have
the moment I had
whoa heck yeah this is awesome isn't
this incredible man why don't they do
Miniatures anymore isn't this how you
just like totally Blown Away obviously
we have some miniature work going on
here but in that sequence what do you
think is Miniatures and what's real at
first glance on that shot where the
camera is pulling back it definitely
looks like the background and all that
stuff was Miniatures well done but then
the cars like tricked my brain out for a
moment because they were moving they
were driving through they looked very
realistic and so my brain wanted to
believe that they were full-scale cars
but then it goes to this shot which does
not look like a miniature shot and maybe
it is actually you know what it probably
is but a higher a bigger scale miniature
what a shot with a handheld motion yeah
this shot's incredible right here that
feels like you're driving on the bridge
with that car but you know
just gotta be part of the set that we've
been seeing this whole time you're 100
right this is like a kid's action figure
dream is what you're telling me yeah
this is actually this entire mega size
miniature set that's like something like
one to four or one to three scale oh wow
so it's okay they're pretty big they had
to actually build this whole set in a
giant airplane hangar at like the Van
Nuys airport really yeah and they're
just saying screw it we're dumping like
650 000 gallons of water wow jeez that's
how big their tank is and it can do like
150 000 gallons per minute because the
thing about
miniature water is that at a certain
point it just doesn't look like full
scale water so if you're involving
Miniatures that have water interacting
with it has to be at a large enough
scale to kind of like tip over into that
large scale format that water acts like
because water acts very different in
large scale versus small scale so that
makes working with miniature stuff very
tricky those are like RC vehicles that
are also being towed you know underneath
the ground you know under like there's
like a little you know it's like a slot
car oh
track yeah because that's the only way
they can have the Precision because with
all the stuff going on if you have like
an RC vehicle exactly RC vehicles are
very difficult to work with yeah like we
know from experience we're trying to
accurately drive that across this it was
lifelike motion onto this bridge also by
the way you've just released a swimming
pool's worth of water and if you want to
refill it it might take a you know a few
phase hours I don't know I don't know
how long it takes to fill those pools
but long enough where you don't want to
mess up these little RC cars that ruin
your shot all these Miniatures are just
incredible Yeah the more I get into
these it's like VFX artists react to
Great Miniatures it's like kind of the
other title of the show because so much
of films from this era and previously
relied on that thank you
watch them one of us died tonight all
right so this is the Watchman movie that
came out in 2009 Alan Moore loves this
movie loves it
[Music]
jokes moving on
the effect shot I'm sorry I think I got
food poisoning I feel like I'm about to
throw up okay you should go do it I'm
sorry oh boy
[Music]
okay we have now subbed in Jordan here
welcome to the couch hey we're going to
continue as if nothing has happened yeah
I don't have food poisoning
yes yes yeah so I wanted to look at this
movie called Watchmen from 2009 have you
seen this oh yes this is one of my
favorites really absolutely okay this
movie is loved but also really hated for
a variety of things but visually no one
can really complain about it and one of
the cool things in this movie was this
character called Rorschach who has this
sort of like psychology Rorschach test
sort of design on his face that's
constantly evolving so let's uh let's
look at some of this
fine
comedian died in New York they could
have very easily just had a bunch of
different you know masks that he puts on
between scenes but no they specifically
wanted to have the design changing every
single second because it's reflecting
who he is as a character in that moment
is he angry is he sad is he vengeful is
he locked in here with everyone else or
are they locked in here with him
best line ever best line ever I'm sure I
did it justice
so for all of these shots they have
really good reference because he's
actually got a real mask over his face
but he's got these big eye holes so he
can still see which is important but the
editor the visual effects artist they
could actually see his performance
through his eyes and his eyebrows as
well so they could use his performance
through his eyes as like cues for when
to go to the next design or what kind of
design to even go to next they created
something like 15 different designs that
were handmade like hand drawn and
whatnot on just regular flat paper and
they were able to take that and
basically use that as a texture on top
of this fabric I believe they used Lycra
I think that's the fabric name that that
sounds like a vegetable
and all they had to do was essentially
just render it out on this sort of cloth
material that's matched move to his face
I see so they of course had to motion
track his head to get that correct
perspective motion and just overall
performance of the shots but they're not
just like 2D motion tracking his face
and putting a design on top of it
they're actually replacing most of his
face oh so they're replacing the cloth
as well well yeah or the fabric rather
exactly of course and then in order to
patch the eye holes it's a lot easier to
just have one seamless fabric than
trying to worry about the trying to
match my little powder exactly trying to
match the pattern in both like scale
size position all that stuff
another interesting aspect of this whole
movie is Dr Manhattan is a CG character
the entire movie there's like 38 minutes
of him on camera in this you know late
2000s so this was a bit of a feat at the
time but the filmmakers had a very
clever idea let's have a real actor
covered in LED lights so he's actually
Illuminating the scene he's Illuminating
the other actors around him and we'll
just replace him which is one of those
things that sounds like a really good
idea on paper but is harder than people
might expect to actually pull off we
don't have time for makeup that blue is
too light for television can you guess
what the problem would be with having a
character completely covered in blue LED
lights
I bet you know the answer I want to hear
Jordan's answer first well I want to
know the right answer
I'm guessing back then they covered him
in the blue LEDs I can tell it's just
messing up the camera sensor in the
behind the scenes footage they're
probably pure blue LEDs which means a
camera sensor which takes red light
green light and blue light in separate
passes is getting nothing for red and
green leading to underexposure and then
way too much blue leading to clipping
which Just Clips out basically to White
all of the behind the scenes footage is
suffering from that exact issue the
digital sensor is not able to like
clearly see the blues so you're getting
these weird artifacts
that's just the fact that those LEDs are
clipping and when they clip in only one
color channel the whole color skews of
that highlight but in the final movie
everything looks so nice the reason why
this worked on the original Watchmen
whereas it did not work in the Obi-Wan
Kenobi show is because they shot this
movie on film
film doesn't burn out to White when it
Clips yeah so as an example let's look
at the shot from the Obi-Wan TV show
[Music]
oh whoa that's tough it like gets darker
yeah and notice how it's not happening
with the red lightsaber either it's
something specific with the blue color
wavelength and digital sensors yeah it's
like a burning little Shadow yeah it's
like it's not brightening the area it's
just shifting it to dark blue from dark
black I can't blame the filmmakers here
because it's such an Obviously good idea
oh let's have everything dark and the
lightsabers are just emitting a ton of
light let's use that as the primary
light source for the scene you should
have some other color mixed with your
blue your color shouldn't ever just be a
full singular blue wavelength it's going
to look ugly you should have a little
bit of other light in there just a
little bit you might be like well that's
a big deal just just desaturate your
blue a little bit just tone the blue
down problem is like when you desaturate
it it's still dark it doesn't like stay
bright as if you shined light on it it
just becomes as dark as the rest of the
image now the interesting thing you're
pointing out is that in Watchmen it's
not quite as bad and that's because film
isn't red green and blue it's actually
silver crystals that break down and the
different crystals break down into the
different wavelengths and so if you're
hitting something with pure blue it's
break down the crystals but you're
getting that interaction amongst all
that those silver crystals so it's still
a smooth roll-off it still affects each
other correctly doesn't clip to White if
you have one color channel it's stronger
than the others you end up just getting
a very saturated version of that color
because they were shooting it all in
film you're having that nice roll-off
it's handling that sort of overexposure
of that color Channel like you're saying
it's just it's just working I I just I
thought that was a really interesting
thing of course they actually did a
whole bunch of really advanced stuff to
actually achieve Dr Manhattan I just
found that sort of anecdote really
interesting like they even had LEDs on
the bottom of his shoes so that whenever
he would take a step it'll illuminate
the floor these are all great ideas and
for Obi-Wan Kenobi I'm sure they perhaps
even referenced this it's like yeah this
is a really good idea and it is hey guys
what should people do if they're not
subscribed to this channel
subscribe
I'm glad we got that one right on the
first try
[Laughter]
welcome to the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen gentlemen German this is The
Avengers but with uh IPS from the 1800s
Parker the chemist oh chemist die
do we get to blow something up then as
there's another man standing in the room
because remember we're talking about
famous eyepiece in the 1800s oh yeah the
Invisible Man The Invisible Man
allow me to introduce myself feels like
a real coat uh felt like a real coat
yeah yeah I imagine it probably is a
real coat but the inside of the code is
CG yeah well you can imagine
it was my young doing just reminder this
is 2003. it looks really nice that's
right there's Roto lines there I want to
see his face oh okay that's that's yeah
it's full CG face are you sure go to the
white so go away go back what do you
mean are you sure go back to the wide
right now because this one because it
looks so it looks real there in that
wide shot my gut was telling me it was
real and then it felt like it was CG but
he was painting it on so my guess is
maybe he was like actually painting on
green paint
or blue paint or what it would have to
uh or white paint what if you had green
beans
the back of the paint that is not an
effect you can get doing practically I
think you're right I think it's green
Man's suit that's CG interior and real
exterior jacket so so far you are right
and it's not green it's blue actually
okay he had like a blue Morphsuit on
they had to paint his head blue except
for his face which was always painted
white and when he's doing this they're
just revealing his face which is already
there and already painted white they
have a 3D head that's tracked onto him
of course so they can show the backside
which is 3D rendered and they can you
know mask out parts of it and leave
holes in there as they want to but his
face moving underneath that that's not
just some crazy hyper Advanced 3D model
for the time that's just his face
covered with white paint okay I'm
totally following what you're talking
about now and here it really DJ to me
especially when you can see through the
hole and you can see like especially
here on this shot obviously we're seeing
the back of it well here's the thing
sometimes you do have a 3D model
obviously it's different techniques for
different moments right this one at the
very beginning here I think might be
real that might be actually revealing
him then I think it moves to a full CG
here because they have to do so much CG
anyways the other side of the face this
I feel like could be either I feel like
it's still 3D but the animation is
animation is really good like that I
think is real right there when he turned
that's actually his face painted white I
mean it's a great blend of techniques
but just having him there with the
makeup and like it's hard obviously to
do the compositing but not impossible by
that point in time you're combining just
real things on top of real things most
often it's crazy that we're looking at
this after the Rorschach thing because
it's like it's the same technique and
it's the same author wow
so you're about to look at it pretty
complicated sequence I want you guys to
break down roughly how you think it was
made
like look at this shot yeah that's
really cool
cool wait hold up those columns are they
just phone columns that explode so like
miniature photography was that miniature
it's it's I feel like it's Miniatures
well it's a lot of different things
isn't it what about that shot we just
saw behind the Cars is whipping around I
want to see CG but then it's 2003. it
definitely didn't look CG to me some of
that actually looks stop-motion to me it
does
whoa oh that's cool that's totally CG
from that top down the car CG yeah how
about the background background it looks
like it's CG the destruction is better
than I'd expected to in 2003 remember we
just saw that we just saw that hallway
shot in Nemo ship right yes
that looked like a lot of projection
mapping stuff to me yeah it looked like
simplified geometry but the fracturing
was better than I'd expect
uh
you're just that sake that's miniature
alrighty it's the end of everything you
go to the behind the scenes ready okay
here we go I'm ready to eat some Humble
Pie
Miniatures okay okay yeah
oh I bet they had so much fun that car
flipped over I was probably not until a
while oh even that oh so there's
composite elements on top of the
miniature wow how cool this looks like
so much fun yeah this is insane like
this is one of those things where you're
watching like how is this so good and
once again it is the Masters at work
like these guys built these one-fifth
scale buildings that weighed a thousand
pounds and these special like scissor
lifts that collapse them hydraulically
so they could do all these different
collapses film all these different
elements and put them all together so it
was crazy City collapsing shots aren't
people doing physics Sims that you
couldn't do back then yes actually just
all practical elements stacked and
stacked and stacked into the footage
it's incredible seeing shots where it's
just like the whole thing is real the
buildings are real the car's real they
have even like the people inside
actually go like this when they turn on
the car yeah
what an unnecessary addition I love it
it's incredible so I don't know how you
couldn't be having fun doing this like
it's pretty cool man this is like
watching this kind of stuff it's like
this was what made me want to be a
filmmaker
foreign
that we made to try to impress the
director of extraction to Sam Hargrave
and you can check it out on a new
episode of punch for punch a show that
we're making for Netflix and it's on
their YouTube channel still watching
Netflix go check it out
it's a big theme of this episode has
been Miniatures I love Miniatures please
leave a suggestion with some movies that
have some of the best miniature effects
you've ever seen thanks so much for
watching we hope Sam will be okay but
Jordan's a pretty good Sam in the
meantime we'll see you guys next week
thanks for tuning in bye